Captain America the Winter Soldier was a
huge success this weekend it made almost
a hundred million dollars the u.s. box
office alone and I'm here to talk about
it spoiler filled so if you have not
seen Captain America you can check out
my spoiler free review that is on my
channel right now because we're going to
talk in depth we're going to get
analytical here we're going to talk
about metaphors and hidden meetings
because yes there's actually some of
those in this Marvel comic book
superhero film there's a lot of awesome
stuff to talk about that I wanted to
talk about in my original video but I
couldn't because I didn't want to spoil
it for you guys I want you guys to go in
there have the best experience possible
so now we get to do that but really
quick got a couple cool things to tell
you first I actually had a chance to be
interviewed at the Captain America
screening by Cleveland comm there's a
video of myself and some other fans who
got all dressed up at the premiere to
see it it's over at Cleveland calm and
let the link for that in the description
below if you want to check that out by
far the biggest comment I've gotten is
that I look absurdly tall in this video
and I do because the reporter was a very
nice lady who happened to be much
shorter than me I am 6 foot 4 a lot of
people were like what are you like 7
foot but no I'm 6 foot 4 I'm not a giant
I guess I am a giant I'm basically as
tall as Liam Neeson and Conan O'Brien
even and Jeff Goldblum by the way I
believe is 6 for good company and also
my audible promotion is still running
and I wanted to tell you guys about that
really quick because I really love
giving back to you guys I've been
looking for ways to give you guys free
stuff because you've given me so much I
have so much fun talking you guys about
movies and audible.com likes what I'm
doing here they're supporting me and
through them I can offer you guys a free
audio book of your choice you can
download anything you want it's got the
new doctor sleep by Stephen King the
sequel to The Shining which is narrated
by will Patton which is awesome because
the shining is a classic book in a
classic movie and it's so cool to see
him do more of that that link is
audible.com slash Chris audible.com
slash Chris just want to tell you guys
about that because it's still going on
it's going to be going on all through
the spring and summer I can give you
guys awesome free stuff and I'm going to
continue to try to find ways in which I
can run promotions like that to give you
guys awesome free stuff so be sure to
check those out they are in the
description I hope you do check that out
alright Captain America the Winter
Soldier this movie blew me away I was so
impressed with this film I could not
believe the levels it went
- a lot of people have messaged me
saying they thought it was overrated and
they thought that I gave it too high of
a grade and that other people are
praising it and they just like all
Marvel movies because they're big
superhero stuff but I got to say I
really feel like this movie went in
different places that the other Marvel
films didn't it felt very grounded for a
Marvel film a lot of things happen in
this movie where you're like what are
they gonna do now like shield is gone
what's gonna happen to the agents of
shield TV shows I just gonna end I'm
guessing maybe they'll be in hiding or
something or they'll have to do things
covertly I don't know now I got to see
this movie at a marathon I saw the first
Captain America film first and then the
second one right after that seeing them
both back-to-back I noticed so many
things about them for one the second one
is so much better in like every way but
one of the things about the first one
that really struck me was that the first
one is very like excuse my french
america yeah we're awesome
patriotism were so cool we're the best
and I love America and oh yeah all that
stuff the second one was like the dark
side of patriotism it showed the
corruption that sometimes goes on in
politics and captains world gets
completely turned around and everything
that he thought he was living for for
his entire life is revealed to be this
corrupt organization and I found that
just riveting it showed the darkness of
that you know it wasn't just like yay
America were the best people ever on the
planet it was like actually no sometimes
some seriously disgusting stuff happens
behind the scenes in the world of
politics and that was so great to take
the Captain America character in a more
dark place because you think about what
are his ideals well America freedom
protecting the people the government and
making sure that all works correctly but
this movie explores all the ways that
those things can go wrong
and how it would affect him in this film
one of the most powerful visual
metaphors that I found to be there in a
Captain America movie is something I
didn't even notice until I had already
seen it twice and I was driving home and
I just went wait a second at the end of
the movie caps stripes literally get
dragged through the wet mud this film
really capitalizes on the fact that
there's a lot of nasty stuff that goes
on behind the scenes and Captain America
has stripes literally just get
completely sullied by it and dirtied by
mud and I found that really powerful and
I don't know if that was the intention
of the filmmakers but to see him all
beaten and downtrodden and shot up and
stabbed and his suits all ripped his
eyes all swollen and he's wet and muddy
and everything just really to me stood
out how really bad politics can be
sometime and how that world can get so
dirty and I found that extremely
powerful one of the things I loved about
this movie was a very beginning when you
see Steve's notepad you see all the
things that he hasn't done or that he is
thinking of doing or has done what's
interesting is what he has written down
is actually different in various
countries depending on where you saw the
film in the UK it has stuff like Sean
Connery on there in the United States
it's got other things too and in Mexico
there were different things as well I
also like how he has Star Wars crossed
off but not Star Trek it's like okay
I've experienced Star Wars I'll get to
Star Trek eventually and I guess maybe
because Disney owns Star Wars now
they're kind of thrown that out there I
don't know it was kind of a cool little
Easter Egg some of the other Easter eggs
I loved in this film was Nick Fury's
grave where it said the path of the
righteous man from Ezekiel that was
totally a reference to Pulp Fiction that
was like the best fanboy Pulp Fiction
Marvel thing I I never would have
thought to go to a Captain America film
and somehow fanboy out about Pulp
Fiction well fan boring about Captain
America it was perfect if anything this
movie proves that Captain America is the
most badass 95 year old in history and
we get to see that in action in that
amazing opening action scene on the boat
and I know from experience that
humongous fans of Captain America
absolutely love the portrayal of his
physicality in this movie this is like
really the first time we're seeing a
truly amazingly awesome badass powerful
guy who can just kick guys off boats as
he's running that long tracking shot
where he's running down the boat he
smacks a guy over the railing up that
was so beautiful one of the biggest
things I loved about this movie was Nick
Fury and the fact that he had so much
more to do as a character his car chase
scene was totally awesome and I loved
seeing him have all these backup things
that he could do and he was trying so
hard to make sure that he was able to
get out of that but the way he was
waiting for like that last second that
was so intense with the musical scored
everything which by the way was a very
simple score at times just a lot of
really electronic noises that kind of
created a pulsating droning vibe kind of
like terminator almost where a lot
that just really worked for especially
for that car chase scene as well as my
favorite scene in the film which is the
highway confrontation between the Winter
Soldier and Captain America and that
entire sequence in the middle of the
movie that's probably my favorite scene
in the movie
I found that scene to be nail-biting
like my eyes were actually watering from
how suspenseful and awesome that action
was it was so well done and it ended
with that great moment where Captain
America realizes that the Winter Soldier
is Bucky now I got to say the reason I
didn't say that the Winter Soldier was
Bucky in my review because a lot of
people are like dude everyone knows what
the winter sold not true
I saw the movie twice okay in theaters
and both times when his mask fell off
and he turned around you saw there was
Bucky I heard audible gasps throughout
the entire theater where people were
like oh my gosh it's Bucky like a lot of
people legitimately did not know that
and that's why I didn't say it in my
review because I'll always do my best to
stray from spoilers unless I warn you
ahead of time but that was just the
perfect villain it was almost like what
they did with the dark night where they
saved that really awesome emotionally
powerful villain for the second one in
the Joker and this one you had red skull
and he's very famous and he's awesome
Hugo Weaving did a really cool job with
him and the skull effects were fantastic
but in the second one you have this
villain that is all of the things that
the red skull was except I had this
extreme personal connection with Captain
America and that's why this villain
works so well however I got a disagree
with some of the statements that he
didn't really have as much weight as he
could have as a character because of
that great scene where Alexander Pierce
Robert Redford and tear gets him about
what he knows and then wipes his memory
and he hits him and everything and he
just like stares I don't like this
really old cracked eyes that Robert
Redford has after he hits them I found
that really intense and it actually
really made me care about the character
of Winter Soldier which is the best way
you can create a compelling villain is
if you actually care about that villain
he's not just some really cool guy who
goes around killing people you actually
feel like you understand his position in
life and you understand why he's doing
the things that he does so yes Nick Fury
didn't really die I gotta be honest I
kind of knew that already because in the
trailer you see a shot where he's like
looks like you're given the orders now
captain and that happens later in the
movie but it hadn't happened yet in the
movie before he died so I was like he's
probably not dead because in the trailer
you saw that shot and you're like okay
so that shots probably coming at some
point right that probably shouldn't been
in the trailer that one shot cuz that
one shot I was like yeah Nick Fury's not
dead black widow was so awesome in this
movie and one of the things I always
liked about her character was the fact
that she is a human you know she's not
gonna jump off a building and just land
and survive she is a vulnerable
character she's gonna get shot she's
gonna get hurt and she could die so that
scene in the middle where she does get
shot and she looks so afraid that's one
of the reasons I love that scene cuz
she's such a badass character and she
doesn't show fear that much it was
really just that and like the scene The
Avengers where she was right next to
Mark Ruffalo before he transform into
the Hulk her character being afraid is
very riveting to me because it shows
that she is a human being and there's
different snippets of that throughout
this film like where she says I just act
like I know everything I don't actually
know everything and I was like okay see
that's cool to see her character
actually admit that she has flaws now of
course the big humongous spoiler of the
film is that this Hydra thing is growing
you know this big Hydra organization is
actually behind a large majority of
shield some people thought that Rob
Redford was going to be the Red Skull
some people still think that he was like
possessed by the Red Skull it's not
clear in the film I wouldn't say
necessarily it was really any of those I
think that he's just a guy who liked the
ideals of that it was trying to go for
it again and I really like the fact they
showed Garry Shandling's character
whisper hail Hydra in the ear of that
other agent because that tells us that
an Iron Man 2 when he was trying to get
Iron Man to stop being Iron Man he's
actually a Hydra agent with all these
different agendas in the background and
that actually flushes out the Iron Man
to film a little more it's this movie
not only was amazing in its own right
but it made the other films before it
better that is a humongous compliment
Anthony Mackie as Falcon was so awesome
in this movie I love the on your left
dynamic and the opening scene that had
that arc at the very end my buddy Craig
candy ko from fat movie guy calm by the
way did a pretty cool Easter egg article
about this himself which I tweeted out
recently he basically said that means
that Falcon is captain's right-hand man
which makes sense I'm not going to say
that that's necessarily like own
representative it's a cool little way of
looking at it for sure basically
everything about Captain America the
Winter Soldier worked for me
love the various Easter eggs in the film
I loved the characters I loved the
action it was so great the score was so
good the fact that the characters were
actually fleshed out you could actually
feel like these are real people as I
said in my original review the one seen
that kind of bugged me was the computer
scene where Zola was in a computer
consciousness a ton of people felt the
need to inform me that that has a basis
in the comics and I know that I'm not
dumb I know my people and just
because I have one problem with the
movie it's not like it to just focus on
that my point really is that just
because a scene has a basis in the
comics it doesn't mean necessarily works
for the film that they're making for
instance if you were watching The Dark
Knight and mr. freeze just suddenly
popped up and froze a couple people and
then ran off it'd be like what it just
felt like it was more science fictiony
than the rest of the film and yeah I got
comments from people saying you can
believe a guy with superhuman powers you
believe Hulk and blah blah blah I'm like
yes I can I just thought it was random
what I didn't like about the scene was
the fact that it felt like it was just
so much villain exposition it just felt
like the character was like I'm gonna
tell you all this and I'm just all I
need to know and here's all the plot
points and I hope you have a nice day oh
by the way I was stalling boom the scene
itself didn't work for me you understand
what I'm saying the two end credits
scenes I thought were very cool the
first one was actually directed by Joss
Whedon and hints at the Avengers 2 it
seems like they have harnessed the power
of Loki's staff perhaps now we see the
twins we see Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch very cool special effects I was
kind of thinking that as this movie
progressed that was like the end credits
thing is probably going to have those
two twins because they have to be set up
in some way for Avengers 2 like there
has to be some hint of them being in
Avengers 2 so I figured you know what
since every character that was in the
first Avengers was mentioned in a
previous film in some way shape or form
they're probably gonna do that for this
one and they did and they look very cool
I'm very excited to see what those twins
do in the New Avengers film I think that
Aaron taylor-johnson and Elizabeth Olsen
are both very good actors so I'm very
much looking forward to seeing their
portrayals of those characters the
second one the very end hints that Bucky
is trying to learn about himself which
hints also that he might be a good guy
soon and that is awesome can you imagine
the Winter Soldier on the good guys side
that is so kick-ass I
love that idea that is so cool in the
comics the Winter Soldier does take over
for Captain America four times so this
is actually a very interesting thing
because Sebastian stay on the guy who
portrays the Winter Soldier his contract
is much longer than Chris Evans so he
could very well take over as Captain
America when Chris Evans decides to
retire that character because recently
he has said he doesn't really want to do
any more acting after his Marvel
contract is up that's a possibility
I love these possibilities they're
awesome I loved Captain America the
Winter Soldier I've seen it twice and
theaters already I can't wait to pick up
the blu-ray and put with my collection
I'm really glad the same directors are
returning for the Captain America 3 film
can't wait to check that out can't wait
to see Avengers 2 I am pumped this movie
finally is like a great Marvel
standalone film because we've had some
ok ones we had some good ones Iron Man
was so great but since then this is by
far the best of the standalone films and
it even exceeds the original Iron Man in
my opinion let me know what you guys
thought of the movie your whole spoiler
thoughts and everything is there's a
spoiler review so go crazy in the
comments and let me know what you guys
thought guys thanks so much for watching
and as always if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
you